عقد رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
لقاءً نادرًا مع مسؤول إسرائيلي رفيع المستوى
الثلاثاء ، حيث قالت هيئة الإذاعة العامة الإسرائيلية
إن محمود عباس
التقى بوزير الدفاع في
الأراضي الإسرائيلية ، وكانت هذه الرحلة الأولى من نوعها
لحافلة منذ أكثر من عقد ،
وأعقبت زيارة للمنطقة في الماضي.  أسبوع
من قبلنا مستشار الأمن القومي جيك
سوليفان لمزيد من المعلومات حول هذا الآن نريد
إحضار أه الصحفي إليوت جوتكين
إنه يعيش من أجلنا آه في القدس تعلمون
أنه قد مر عقدًا من الزمان لرئيسه من الواضح أن
هذا مثير للاهتمام
ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا عن  التوقيت
وما هي الأهمية التي قد يحملها
بول أعتقد قبل أن نناقش
أهمية هذا الاجتماع يجب أن
نوضح ما لا يعنيه هذا وما لا
يعنيه هو عودة
محادثات السلام أه بين إسرائيل
والفلسطينيين فهم لا يزالون محتضرين  مع
عدم وجود توقع أو أمل في
أنه سيكون هناك أي تقدم على تلك الجبهة
لأسباب ليس أقلها
أعضاء الجناح اليميني في إسرائيل التي تحكم
ائتلاف يضم حزب رئيس
الوزراء نفتالي بينيت ، لذا فإن هذا ما
لم يكن هذا الاجتماع على ما كان
عليه لعدة أسباب من حيث الأهمية ،
أحدها هو تعزيز موقف
رئيس السلطة الفلسطينية
عباس وأيضًا على حساب
حماس محمود.  بالطبع يتحكم في قطاع غزة
ويظهر أنه لا يزال
حقًا الشخص الوحيد الذي يستطيع الإسرائيليون
والولايات المتحدة التعامل معه أه
فيما يتعلق بالفلسطينيين على الرغم من
أنه مثل 15 عامًا في فترة أربع
سنوات أه الأسباب الأخرى و  لماذا
يحدث الآن كما تقول كان لدينا
جيك سوليفان أه
مستشار الأمن القومي من الولايات المتحدة أه هنا في إسرائيل
أه قبل أسبوع فقط لقاء أه مع
رئيس الوزراء نفتالي بينيت
ومحمود عباس وكذلك أظهر أه
أن الولايات المتحدة هي  - الانخراط في أه مع الوضع
الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني
على عكس الطريقة التي
لم تكن منخرطة حقًا في ظل الإدارة الرابحة
علاوة على ذلك بالطبع
رأينا ارتفاعًا في  العنف في
الضفة الغربية على حد سواء من قبل الفلسطينيين ضد
المستوطنين الإسرائيليين والمستوطنين الإسرائيليين
ضد الفلسطينيين كذلك لذلك
كانت هذه أيضًا فرصة
للحديث لمحاولة تهدئة الوضع
أه وإه لمحاولة ذلك على حد تعبير أه
وزير الدفاع الحميدة
تواصل  مع دفع
إجراءات بناء الثقة أه حتى
يمكن تهدئة الأوضاع والتوترات
أه إلى حد ما
ونأمل من وجهة نظر
الإسرائيليين بتحسين الوضع الاقتصادي والأمني
سيكون على لس
ن وزير الدفاع جانز خير لل
ير-  كونهم من الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين